monsieur giscardestin bonsoir si je suis
là pour vous interroger ce soir c'est
que malgré le débat d'hier vous n'avez
pu faute de temps répondre à toutes les
questions que les Français se posent or
c'est je crois le rôle d'un journaliste
indépendant de poser les questions que
se pose le public alors première
question on a longuement parlé hier soir
de ce qui pourra se passer au lendemain
de l'élection on a évoqué les scénarios
possibles ma première question première
demande de précision est simple si vous
êtes élu dimanche êtes-vous tout à fait
sûr d'avoir une majorité au Parlement en
êtes-vous si sûr merci Monsieur bouot de
me poser ces questions je vous rappelle
à propos de la durée du débat hier que
j'avais proposer deux débats pensant
qu'en effet le nombre de questions à
traiter justifi deux débats au lendemain
d'élection présidentielle naturellement
je serai assuré d'une majorité puisque
les électeurs français se seront
exprimés deux fois en mars 1978 en
élisant l'actuelle majorité et en mai
1981 en élisant le président de la
République et si les électeurs ont
confirmé deux fois leur votes
majoritaire bien entendu les élus
respecteront le le vote de leurs
électeurs et il y aura donc une majorité
on pourra se remettre tout de suite au
travail on aurit pas de problème avec le
RPR c'est ça que les gens se demandent
final il n aura pas de problème vous
avez vu d'ailleurs queà l'heure actuelle
la totalité pratiquement des
parlementaires RPR s'est prononcé en
faveur de ma candidature et d'ailleurs
participe très largement à la campagne
du second tour alors quelle sera
l'activité le déroulement de l'activité
gouvernementale ceci se passera de la
manière suivante d'abord dans un premier
temps des consultations il faut voir
tous ceux qui ont participé à cette
campagne de façon à recueillir leur avis
sur les préoccupations que les Français
ont voulu exprimer ensuite nomination du
Premier ministre et du gouvernement puis
ce que j'appelle les états généraux de
la majorité c'est-à-dire une réunion
très très ouverte sans formalité de
l'ensemble des parlementaires
appartenant à la majorité au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale pour qu'ils
examinent avec le gouvernement les
grandes orientations de l'action à
poursuivre pendant le reste de la
législature un programme pour les 2 ans
de la législature et enfin la mise au
travail de l'Assemblée nationale sur des
sujets d'actualité je dira même
d'urgence les premières dispositions à
voter devront intéresser l'emploi et
notamment l'emploi des jeunes voilà donc
ce qui se passera si je suis élu
c'est-à-dire pas de dissolution vous
êtes formel j'exclus totalement la
dissolution il y a aucune perspective de
dissolution alors si c'est mon
concurrent qui est élu la situation est
complètement différente et il l' exposé
clairement hier soir pour la première
fois vous avez noté qu'après certaines
hésitation il a indiqué qu'il
dissoudrait tout de suite l'Assemblée
nationale finalement il la réunira même
pas et il diss sououdra tout de suite il
renverra donc la majorité qui a été élue
par les Françaises et les Français en
mars 1978 qui a été élu par vous et
ensuite il procédera à de nouvelles
élections et pour la préparation de ces
élections il a indiqué que devrait se
nouer une négociation entre le Parti
socialiste et le Parti communiste or
cette négociation se déroulera dans un
temps précipité puisque le calendrier
est extrêmement court et dans une
situation de faiblesse pour le président
de la République et pour son parti
parce que comme il aura renvoyé la
majorité existante il est essentiel pour
lui s'il veut maintenir son autorité que
revienne une majorité qui ne soit pas
celle qu'il a chassé lui-même et donc il
sera lié au succès de cette majorité
socialiste et communiste et les
communistes pourront poser leurs
exigences pour établir cet accord
électoral réfléchissez à un instant ce
ne sont pas les députés qui auront été
renvoyés auxquels on pourra demander
leur suffrage pour exécuter une
politique qui sera contra précisément à
leurs engagements si bien que la
négociation entre les socialistes et les
communistes se fera comment les
communistes diront le minimum c'est
votre projet vous avez fait un projet le
projet socialiste en juin 1980 ça c'est
le départ et nous allons situer les
solutions entre votre projet et notre
projet communiste si bien que le projet
socialiste sera le minimum de ce que les
le gouvernement s'engagera à accomplir
alors je vous rappelle quelques
caractéristiques de ce projet je les ai
évoqué hier soir suppression de du
régime autonome de la retraite des
cadres puisqu'il y aura le
déplafonnement de toutes les cotisations
en ce qui concerne les agriculteurs
office foncier cantonau pour régler le
problème de l'utilisation et de
l'affectation des terres office foncier
cantonau ils savent ce que cela veut
dire pour les médecins je pourrais vous
lire le texte je vous fais des extraits
ce sont des extraits du texte vers un
service communautaire de santé le rôle
pilote sera confié au centre de soins
agréé et ceci vaut également en ce qui
concerne le ré régime de la pharmacie
pour l'armée les comités de soldats vous
voyez la situation de notre défense dans
les temps que nous allons traverser avec
une armée organisé autour de comité de
soldat pour la société les mœurs
libéralisation totale de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse avec suppression
par exemple de l'autorisation pour les
mineurs chose que nous avons refusé lors
de l'adoption du texte et un certain
nombre de dispositions fiscales de porté
considérabl voilà ce que sera le minimum
de ce que les Français verront appliqué
au cours de cette période moi je
voudrais qu'on r viienne à vous monsieur
giscardestin et au débat d'hier soir les
points d'éclaircissement hier soir comme
tout au long de la campagne monsieur
miteran et vous-même vous avez fait des
promesses mais on n pas beaucoup chiffré
on a même pas chiffré du tout et je suis
sûr que les Français voudraient savoir
combien tout ça va leur coûter très
volontiers vous avez vu que j'ai fait
peu de promesses j'ai indiqué les
directions dans lesquelles l'effort
devrait être poursuivi effort de
solidarité dont j'ai indiquer qu'il
serait poursuivi personnes âgées famille
handicapé travailleurs annuel femme seul
et pour lesquelles nous continuerons
l'effort engagés au cours du septena
précédent que que nous avons été capable
de financer j'ai pris un engagement
financier nouveau précis qui concerne
l'emploi des jeunes je peux vous dire
que le chiffrage de ce projet est de
l'ordre de 2 milliards de francs pour la
première année 81 puisque ça démarre
progressivement de l'ordre de 7
milliards de francs pour la 2e année de
l'ordre de 10 milliards de francs pour
la 3e année si on voit la progression
des ressources fiscales de la France
nous pouvons financer un tel projet
alors par contre si je prends le
programme de mon concurrent vous savez
que le chiffrage qui a été fait par le
ministère du Budget aboutit à des
dépenses de l'ordre de 300 milliards de
francs bon 300 milliards de francs
personne ne sait ce que c'est et les
téléspectateurs doivent se dire
qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est chiffres
ça veut dire le die du revenu national
de la France on on dépenserait en plus
le 10e de notre revenu national alors
naturellement j'imagine que mon
concurrent dira qu'il va étaler son
programme mais même s'il l'étale les
évaluations les plus réaliste qu'on
puisse faire montre que nous aurions un
déficit budg budgétaire de 100 milliards
de francs en 82 et un déficit extérieur
de 100 milliards de francs également en
82 qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ces
chiffres et bien pour le déficit
budgétaire ça veut dire le triplement du
déficit actuel et d'ailleurs hier soir
monsieur mitteran à votre place a dit en
effet je reconnais que vous avez
maintenu le déficite dans des limites
étroites et donc il y a une marge pour
l'augmenter mais ce déficit comment le
financera-t-on et s'il y a une création
de monnaie l'effet automatique les
Français il sont habitués lar depuis
longtemps c'est l'accélération de la
hausse des prix et si vous prenez le
déficit extérieur 100 milliards on dit
qu'est-ce que c'est et bien c'est
l'équivalent des deux chocs pétroliers
précédents qui ont désorganisé notre
économie et qui nous ont en réalité
plongé dans la crise alors voilà l'ordre
de grandeur 100 milliards de déficit
budgétaire 100 milliards de déficit
extérieur et une indication les
allocations familiales on propose une
augmentation très forte des allocations
familiales comme nous avons fait une
politique en faveur de la famille les
comptes des allocations familiales sont
cette année juste équilibré il y a même
un léger déficit parce que nous avons
simplement à dépenser l'argent pour les
familles ce qui est fait comme
proposition entraînerait une
augmentation des cotisations parce que
c'est payé par des cotisations de 2
points et demi de plus qu'il faudrait
donc instaurer sur les salaires 2 point
et demi de plus pour payer le supplément
d'allocation familiale voilà le quelques
exemples du coût de la facture moi je
voudrais revenir à vous monsieur
jcardesttin et et en particulier sur le
plan fiscal n'est-ce pas les engagements
que vous pouvez prendre et et que les
gens euh attendent parce que ça ils
savent ce que ça veut dire en matière
d'impôt nouveaux en matière de pression
fiscale nous avons commencé à préparer
le budget de 82 nous l'avons commencé à
le préparer prudemment puisque il y
avait l'échéance présidentielle je peux
vous dire qu'il n'y aura pas de création
d'impôt nouveaux je suis quelqu'un qui
toute ma vie a lutté contre
l'accroissement de la pression fiscale
et donc il n'y aura pas de création
d'impôt nouveaux il y aura même
l'élargissement des tranches du barem ce
que j'ai indiqué pour compenser les
effets de la hausse des prix et même
avec un effort particulier qui devraitre
ser étalé sur plusieurs années pour être
réaliste en faveur des catégories que
j'appellerais petites et moyennes où
notre Baret est trop serré la
progressivité de l'impôt est trop forte
et mon objectif c'est de réduire
progressivement le taux du prélèvement
global sur l'économie française il a
augmenté c'est vrai mais il a augmenté
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait la crise et
que nous avions des efforts de
solidarité à faire en faveur des
chômeurs en faveur des personnes âgées
des familles toutes sortes de groupes
qui étaient touchés par la crise mais au
fur et à mesure que notre situation
améliorera je souhaite que nous
puissions réduire notre prélèvement
fiscal global qui est en effet à l'heure
actuelle trop lourd ça dire renverser
une tendance car on est sur une tendance
d'augmentation la vérité c'est qu'on a
commencé à l'arrêter cette année si vous
regardez mais n'entrons pas dans ces
détails le budget de 1981 préparé par
l'actuel gouvernement marque déjà en
réalité l'arrêt de la tendance mais il
faudra en effet accentuer cet effort
donc jegist pas d'impôt nouveau rien sur
les successions rien sur le reste enfin
c'est c'est formel ça c'est tout à fait
formel monsieur Moot mais alors par
contre je vous indique appelle les
projets fiscaux de mon concurrent sur
quelques points par exemple on critique
le système des plus-values il faut le
simplifier d'ailleurs mais nous avons
exonéré totalement la résidence
principale la maison individuelle dans
le projet qui est que j'ai ici je peux
vous le lire au contraire la résidence
principale à partir d'un certain seuil
rentre dans le système des plus-values
fiscales alors je le dis aux millions de
Françis nous avons rendu propriétaire de
leur maison deuxième exemple les droits
de succession qu'on ne dise pas que
c'est un projet en l'air un amend je
l'avais porté hier soir a été déposé à
l'Assemblée nationale au mois d'octobre
avec le numéro 40 et qui propose de
porter de 20 % ce qui est le taux actuel
à 45 % à partir de 500000 francs les
droits de succession en ligne directe
c'est-à-dire entre parents et enfants ou
entre mari et femme 500000 francs vous
voyez ce que c'est c'est-à-dire pour un
exploitant agricole ou pour un
commerçant pour un artisan pour
quelqu'un qui est même propriétaire d'un
logement un peu important on fera passer
le taux des droits de succession de 20 %
à 45 %. et bien vous savez qu'à l'heure
actuelle le problème pour l'agriculture
pour la petite exploitation c'est
justement la transmission de
l'exploitation et du patrimoine et bien
dans ce cas-là les droits deviendrai des
droits qui ne pourraient plus être
supportés en réalité par nos petites
exploitations individuelles or ceci a
été proposé déposé à l'Assemblée
national voilà les projets fiscaux je
vrais qu'on revienne à l'emploi monsieur
juscard destin car vous avez au début de
la campagne présenté un plan sur
l'emploi
on en a parlé hier soir mais moi je
manque de précision là-dessus je
voudrais savoir combien vous allez créer
d'emploi si vous êtes réélu et en
combien de temps des chiffres et un
calendrier ça on l'a pas eu hier soir
alors je voudrais que sur ce problème de
l'emploi là aussi il faudrait en effet
de long débatce parce que je reconnais
la gravité et l'importance du problème
ceux qui me critiquent en tirent une
conséquence fausse et injuste qui
consiste à dire ah vous voyez vous ne
vous êtes pas occupé de ce problème nous
n'avons pas cessé de nous en occupé et
je vous donne deux exemples premier
exemple ce matin au Conseil des
ministres on nous a rendu compte du
dernier pacte national pour l'emploi tel
qu'il vient de se dérouler depuis le
mois de septembre jusqu'à la fin du mois
de mars nous avons obtenu l'embauche de
488000 travailleurs au au titre de ce
Pact avec des actions qui sont des
actions qui préparent l'avenir de la
France pour les contrats d'apprentissage
123400 alors qu'il y a quelques années
nous étions au niveau de 60000 12 3400
et pour les stages pratiques en
entreprise qui est une formule nouvelle
et dans laquelle contrairement à ce
qu'on dit les jeunes restent au travail
dans la proportion des 3/4
144500 recrutements donc simplement pour
vous dire voilà ce qui a été accompli au
cours des 9 mois qui viennent de s'achev
et quand on parle de la situation on
dépint la France comme étant n'ayant pas
accompli l'effort qu'ont accompli les
autres les statistiques européennes
viennent d'être publié elles ne sont pas
nationales pour pas dire que nous les
avons manipulé ou préparé en un an de
mars 80 à mars 81 le chômage augmenté en
Angleterre de 68 %. le chômage augmenté
au pays bar de 63 % en Allemagne
fédérale de 38 % et en France de 17 %
nous sommes le pays qui a le mieux lutté
en ce qui concerne l'emploi mais je rép
c'est pas la question monsieur la
question pour les Français c'est combien
va-t-on créer l'emploi 1 million
d'emplois d'ici 1985 1 million d'emplois
ce qui correspond si vous voulez au
supplé de l'arrivée des jeunes sur le
marché du travail d'ici 1985 1 million
d'emplois de plus comment d'une part par
la création d'emploi d à l'activité
économique d'où notre programme
d'investissement et notre grand emprunt
franco-allemand pour que les entreprises
étant plus compétitives créent de
nouveaux emplois et embauche et ensuite
une série de dispositions particulières
qui touche vous le savez la formation
professionnelle les recettes les
retraites anticipées sur une base
volontaire l'introduction et le
développement du travail à temps partiel
l'élimination des abus dans le le
système de l'indemnisation du chômage
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire pour
pour inciter pour aider les petites et
les moyennes entreprises à créer des
emplois et est-ce que c'est possible et
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose dans
votre plan làus oui d'une part d'une
part il faut alléger certaines de leurs
charges notamment celles qui sont au
voisinage de ce qu'on appelle les seuils
ces seuils qui freineent certainement la
création d'emplois il faut alléger les
charges au voisinage de ces seuils il
faut leur donner des facilités de crédit
ce qui sera fait au titre du grand
emprunt et il faut enfin permettre à
certains travailleurs de conserver une
partie de les de chômage lorsqu'ils se
remettent au travail pour que ces
allocations soient une incitation à la
remise au travail et non pas une
incitation à demeurer dans une situation
de demandeurs d'emploi qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ceux qui disent dans le
fond vous visez moins à créer les
emplois qu'à répartir le chômage c'est
ça votre polique tout notre politique au
contraire est une politique de
développement économique et industriel
de la France et quand je dis création
d'un million d'emplois ça veut dire
création d'un million d'emplois alors je
voudrais simplement vous dire pour
prévenir les Français en particulier nos
nos jeunes compatri riote que si le
programme de l'opposition est mise en
application s'il y a cette majoration
des charges tout de suite augmentation
massive du SMIC dès le prochain mois et
augmentation des contraintes et des
charges sur les entreprises petites et
moyennes nationalisation de tout le
système bancaire ce qui veut dire que
tout le patrimoine des Français sera
entre les mains d'organismes dépendants
de l'État pour la première fois dans
notre histoire s'il y a menace de
nationalisation qui fait que la moitié
de notre industrie sera nationalisée il
n'y aura plus une création d'emploi en
France au cours de cette période je dis
aux téléspectateurs chacun connaît un
chef d'entreprise petit ou grand parfois
petit naturellement mais qui qui qui
peut tenir un garage ou une petite
entreprise artisanale ou un commerce qui
a quelques employés ou une exploitation
agricole renseignez-vous si on annonce
la mise en place d'un tel programme
aucun chef d'entreprise ne créera
d'emplois nouveau à partir de l'été 1981
et comme il va arriver 200000 jeunes par
mois 200000 en juillet 200000 en a
200000 en septembre
ils seront devant une économie
désorganisée où aucun chef d'entreprise
ne procédera à l'heure actuelle à des
embauches nouvelles et c'est ce qui veut
dire que le risque en réalité il n'est
pas de mon côté parce que de notre côté
nous avons les moyens de poursuivre
notre politique de création d'emploi
nous n'introduisons aucun désordre dans
l'économie alors que la désorganisation
de l'économie est incompatible avec
l'offre d'emploi nouveau dans les
prochains mois un mot de politique
étrangère si vous le permettez car le
temps presse il m'a semblé beaucoup
d'observateurs que sur ces sujets de
politique étrangère dans le fond il y
avait pas de désaccords fondamentaux
entre vous et Monsieur miteran hier soir
estce que nous som quand on parle de de
politique étrangère en termees généraux
il n'y a jamais de de désaccords
fondamentaux simplement la les
désaccords sont dans les moyens et dans
les moyens c'est la liberté d'agir or
j'indique que mon concurrent n'aurait
pas la liberté d'agir en matière de
politique étrangère pour deux raisons
d'abord parce qu'en matière de défense
sa position ne serait pas crédible il a
proposé en 1973 l'arrêt de notre force
nucléaire de dissuasion il a voté je
l'ai rappelé hier soir contre toutes les
lois programmes d'équipement de nos
forces quelle serait alors sa
crédibilité au titre de l'usage de la
dissuasion française qui croirait que
quelqu'un qui s'est opposé à la
constitution d'une force est décidé ou
déterminé à en faire usage si c'était
nécessaire pour les besoins de la France
première limitation de sa possibilité
d'agir la seconde c'est que les options
de politique étrangère de sa majorité
seraient des options qui lui
retireraient une liberté d'action
vis-à-vis vie de certains des grands
dirigeants du monde alors qu'au
contraire la majorité actuelle m'a
permis par son soutien d'avoir une
grande liberté d'action en ce qui
concerne la conduite de la politique
étrangère de la France donc il n'aurait
pas la liberté d'agir et cela veut dire
soyons clair le déclin de l'influence de
la France dans le monde une dernière
question à vous poser monsieur
jcardestin qui qui déborde d'ailleurs le
débat d'hier vous avez dit au début de
votre campagne si je suis réélu ce ne
sera pas un nouveau septena ce sera un
septena nouveau est-ce que vous avez
conscience du désir de changement des
Français qui manifestement est profond
bien entendu j'ai conscience de ce désir
d'ailleurs tout au long de la campagne
je l'ai rencontré ce désir de changement
il faut savoir que désir de changement
en même temps il a joué des mauvais
tours à la France et que dans le passé
on a parfois changé pour connaître des
situation plus difficile faut rappelle
les dictons de la sagesse française
n'est-ce pas un bon tien vaut mieux que
deux tu l'uras les Français savent ça
depuis longtemps mais il y a ce désir de
changement et ce désir de changement je
le reconnais et moiême Mme ayant pendant
C temps conduit une certaine action
d'une certaine manière je souhaite le
renouvellement parce que la vie nous
change la vie vous a changé monsieur
moujot la vie m'a changé je souhaite
conduire une action nouvelle c'est cela
qui qui m'intéresse et qui est mon mon
ambition profonde alors nouvelle comment
je crois d'abord un septénin plus ouvert
pour des raisons politiques diverses
notre situation c'était tendue c'était à
certains égards crispé en matière
politique il faut que les relations
soient plus ouvertes au sein de la
majorité et j'espère même au-delà il
faut peut-être êre un sepéna plus humain
et les contraintes de la crise nous ont
amené à nous concentrer sur certains
sujets ou nous préoccuper de de la
politique par exemple économique en y
consacrant toute notre attention mais il
y a aussi la dimension humaine des
choses et des problèmes on vous le
reproche souvent d'être un peu loin des
gens non je crois pas qu'on me le
reproche à moi mais on le reproche à ma
fonction VO je voudrais que ma fonction
soit plus humaine c'est pas moi parce
que moi j'ai toujours eu des rapports
directs et faciles avec ceux que je
rencontre mais je vrais que la fonction
président de la République en France de
devienne une fonction plus humaine
traité comme telle et en ce qui me
concerne naturellement assumer comme tel
et enfin je souhaiterais que ce septena
soit tourné vers l'avenir que tout le
monde le sente vous parliez tout à
l'heure du problème de l'emploi ça n'est
pas en nous tournant vers le passé qu'on
résoudra c'est en nous tournant vers
l'avenir or j'ai développé les capacités
de la France nous avons acquis notre
indépendance énergétique nous avons
développé des grands secteurs d'avenir
des réussites nationale nous devons
aller plus loin de façon à ce que on
s'aperçoive que la France est un pays
qui avance en direction de la l' avenir
et qui règle ses problèmes en avançant
au lieu de les régler en se tournant
vers le passé et cela exprime aussi
permettez-moi de le dire une ambition
pour la France je voudrais que ce
septena nouveau apparaisse comme un
septena de l'influence de la grandeur du
rayonnement de mon pays de notre pays la
France monsur jcin je vous remercie
d'avoir répondu très franchement à des
questions qui étaient qui se voulaient
très
directes
[Musique]